[Music]
as revealed by your grandfather
the second Chief Minister of the fourth
magistrate this is all you need
this program
is called the parable of the pirate and
the King and we cross out the random and
acts of finest because it's an evolution
through Dimensions specifically the
fifth and sixth Dimension as as we get
to the latter episodes so by the time
you get to The Fifth Dimension they're
living in parallel timelines
simultaneously
[Music]
oh
one timeline in which they go back to
Liberia on land that nausea inherited
the plantation of former rubber
Plantation and also parallel to that to
Hays County Texas on land that terence's
family received as a reparation and
we're experiencing their experience of
being in those parallels as people who
know how to navigate that as people who
have some understanding of the Dynamics
of interdimensionality and
who makes stories about it you know and
knowledge this case makes a game about
it Tourette is hard to do the trauma of
200 years of chattel sling coded in your
nervous system a gun in your hand a
Bible in the other life on the imprint
of enslavement in
[Music]